[Music]
welcome back as we mentioned in the
angle some politicians are using the New
York City terror attack to foment a
totally false narrative about terrorism
and immigration to make matters worse
the media they seem to have no problem
in van seing the storyline for example
just hours after the attack NBC News
offered this headline muslim-americans
again brace for backlash after New York
attack they're concerned for the eight
dead victims it's just positively
overwhelming The Associated Press posted
a tweet this morning saying quote
investigators seek motive after driver
in a rented truck mowed down people on a
bike path in New York City motive
he yelled Allahu Akbar after you carried
out the attack and requested an Isis
flag in his hospital room you don't need
to be Columbo to figure that one out
joining us for reaction here in
Washington is Democratic strategist and
adjunct professor David good friend and
in New York is Ann Coulter it nationally
syndicated columnist it's great to see
both of you and let's start with you I
mean the cries of Islamophobia I mean
how long did it take Ann maybe I don't
know 15 minutes after the terror attacks
in New York it's like clockwork six
hours NBC News and a tweet for those
keeping count know the media is very
very predictable the media is on the
side of the Democrats and the Democrats
haven't been changing any minds recently
it's not like they have good ideas
they're bringing in ringers they want
this constant transformation of America
so they can win elections in fact it's
come up just this week with with the
Virginia election with I think it was in
The Washington Post no the New York
Times Democrats fretting that maybe all
of the Hispanics that have moved into
Virginia may not come out and vote for
the Democrat against against Gillespie
this is all about the vote for the
Democrats for the Republicans the
corrupt Republicans it's all because
their donors want the cheap labor but
don't imagine that Democrats are
changing any minds here David on the
issue of this diverse diversity visa
program like 50,000 individuals get a
lot a lot is like a Powerball for for
visas
that we're really where we should be
today given given the labor market given
the fact that you know we have a lot of
still minorities who are looking for
work who need better jobs and I don't I
don't really get it we're pretty diverse
country increasingly diverse now why do
we need a diversity program well look
Laura first of all I come from the Upper
Midwest I know about factories that have
shut down and I know a lot of the
concerns about finding jobs for people
here at home but I want the first words
I say about this to be that I'm thinking
about the families of those eight people
I think we all should take a deep breath
and realize real people were killed real
people are hurt and we shouldn't allow
ourselves to be terrorized by the
terrorists I'm gonna ride my bike down a
path here in Washington DC tomorrow I'm
gonna ride the Metro I won't be
intimidated these are the kind of things
we should be talking about unifying us
great guy but I mean that's just the
stuff we hear all the time I'm resilient
of course we're resilient we're
Americans we all know that well but my
best about the program yes about that
day would be alive if we didn't have
that cockamamie program in place
well that's lying but Laura that's like
me saying there'd be people alive in Las
Vegas if we didn't have assault weapons
for sale how do you react to that well I
think in this case we have a second
amendment that actually gives us the
right I sleep and buried our you don't
have a constitutional right well no
you're gonna I'm gonna get some Pakistan
you're helping that give me insight into
the mind of a conservative so because
the Second Amendment is there you think
that the shooting and the gun sales are
okay that's the complete ology that is
not that that's not exactly what I'm
saying okay well what I'm saying I think
liberals have made have gone too far
this is why Trump got elected and I
think everyone gets their blinders on
you know and written books about this
you know I've talked about it for years
we get in our blinders and we think okay
we have the right answers but you fear
that most peanuts people in the country
aren't all that political most people
dream about politics they want it food
on the table they want safety agree they
want security they maybe save a little
for retirement this seems to make not a
lot of sense to most Americans I bet if
you did a poll on this and an you can
chime in just on this issue of the
diversity visa you guys like a random
guy and upstate New York should we have
a diversity
yes people down south between California
it's Hispanic immigrants and they're not
seeing a lot of hikes in their wages
either do you think they're all yeah we
need more diversity from I don't think
so I think the demin
you keep bringing up I think a fantastic
point you've brought it up with all of
your guests and I would like to more
fully answer it and that is this
religion of diversity no diversity is is
its it's just treated like it's
automatically a good thing like the word
organic and we have diversity Plus
lottery because you know that's how Kate
Upton picks who she's gonna date she has
a lottery otherwise professional
professional sports players and rock and
rollers they'd have the inside track you
know the Astros should be getting chess
players and the Avs yeah oh gosh with
clubfoot it's crazy we are the greatest
country in the world we should be
choosing our people who are going to be
our fellow citizens the way the Astros
and the Dodgers choose their players and
not be taking people with club feet it's
it's our choice and whenever Americans
find out the way any aspect of our
immigration policy is run it is not
popular the Democrats don't want to talk
about it unfortunately until Donald
Trump no Republican wanted to talk about
it all can go well and I want to ask you
this question because I'm really curious
to know the answer there was a
legislative proposal put forward by
Republicans and Democrats to get rid of
this program and have a blanket reform
that was rejected in the house do you
support that do you support that
bipartisan effort to reform immigration
it was rejected as part of a plan to
amnesty 30 million eight out of the
diversity lottery we do not want to
amnesty 30 million illegals we have a
hard break here guys but this is a great
segment and a really good conversation I
want to have you both back phenomenal
thanks for being with